make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into Avengers vol
2 again like we're kind of playing
catch-up here you know I didn't even
realize I went back and looked at my
uploads I didn't realize there was a
point where I didn't upload for almost a
month but I had a lot of things going on
anyway so catching up with Avengers uh
this comes in the aftermath of the final
house now those are guys who have not
seen my video on the final host you'll
find that down in the description but
that was basically Jason Aaron kind of
retconning everything and saying like
the origins of like all life on Earth
stemmed from like the first celestial
that ever showed up here and then
basically bled all over the place but
with this issue definitely the first
issue issue number eight of Avengers
really just kind of fleshes out the
Avengers team as it exists now there's
not a lot doing here and it's really
kind of Jason Aaron just sort of setting
the stage as it stands right now the
existing roster of the Avengers are
composed of Doctor Strange who's kind of
in and out like Panther Captain America
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel you've got
she-hulk you basically kind of have like
the the normal runabout of teammates
that you would expect to see Thor of
course as a mainstay has been for quite
some time but the big kind of take away
from all this from really the first
issue is one Black Panther is made the
chairman of the team which is a big
departure from history and Marvel Comics
Captain America has always been a leader
of the Avengers team and it's kind of
cool to kind of put black panther in
that role because Black Panther is one
exceedingly intelligent he's also stupid
rich and then at the same time like he's
wildly capable probably more capable
than Captain America is in terms of his
abilities and what he can do but one of
the other big things that comes from
this is basically rocks on oil now rocks
on is not a corporation that we talk
about all that often and Marvel Comics
and you guys are probably seen at
referenced in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but rocks on oil is one of
these like multinational corporations
that's just like corrupt as hell like
that's basically what it is like there
that's like the super corrupt
organization that literally just does
almost anything that they want to do but
in this instance they're basically
hunting for various forms of wildlife
we're not totally explicitly what
they're doing but whatever they're doing
is basically pissed off the Atlanteans
the result is that like three of them
end up attacking and when they do rocks
on oil kills them and then strange them
up and basically hangs them from the
side of the ship which pisses off the
name of the Submariner now this is kind
of the crazy thing because namely the
Submariner is usually reserved and what
is up happening here in this instance is
like he literally snaps and what he's
done is sworn like all surface dwellers
are not to be here and the action is of
summoning stingray of course stingray
goes way back you know in the name war
stories and they were friends at one
point but he literally beats it within
an inch of his
and since Noah for the service world can
be here but the fact remains that it's
one of these things where name wars
basically kind of sworn a vendetta
against the surface world
it's basically what's going on here now
on the surface it would be easy to
dismiss this and the reason why is
because name wars never really been
considered like a worthwhile character
and I mean depending on the circumstance
he has but name was one of those
characters where I always found to be
interesting when he wasn't really
fighting per se but when you focus on
the nature of his character that's what
made him so cool during Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers is it was a
lot of like dialogue focusing on him and
the fact that like I'll do whatever it
takes to win for most people is very
easy to kind of write off namor the
sub-mariner and so for name war fans
this is kind of like their yeah like see
like I told you name war was legit any
any really is the the funny thing about
him is that name war is more often than
not seen on the surface but when name
wars in the ocean he's a hoss and that's
the funny thing is because name war it
basically intends to like like literally
take all these soldiers these these guys
from Roxxon who killed the Atlanteans
and execute them himself
now the Avengers are here and the reason
why is because the Avengers are kind of
like a safety measure here because if
word got out that name of the Submariner
took surface-dwellers took him down to
Atlantis and then killed them that would
spark a war with the surface like
literally would be like okay so like all
bets are off and the Atlanteans would go
to war with the surface but when the
Avengers show up they're like you have
to hand the prisoners over we're trying
to avoid a conflict and then where's
response is no and literally goes
toe-to-toe with all the Avengers he
crushes Thor's hammer with his bare
hands he wrecks Captain Marvel by hers
like literally crushes her she-hulk it's
gets like completely and totally
overwhelmed he totally overwhelms Ghost
Rider Robby Reyes I mean everyone who
goes like every single member of the
Avengers who goes before name worked
Falls and ultimately it's all kind of
stopped by Captain America now this is
kind of an interesting thing here
because what Jason Aaron does is instead
of sort of copying out he plays on the
role of Captain America and what I mean
by that is in Marvel Comics while I
don't really consider Captain America to
be wildly interesting in and of himself
although the current like winner in
America's story is actually pretty cool
but the cool thing about this is that
Captain America's reputation sort of
precedes him and so it's one of these
things worse like okay because you're
Captain America I will listen to you but
only because you're Captain America
because Captain America is usually
diplomacy first fighting second so it
makes sense it like when Captain America
steps that steps up that is I don't want
to fight you like I want to have a
conversation as though really as kind of
Jason Aaron sort of stopping the
conflict and then letting things sort of
continue but remember name was earnest
in his home territory I mean they're
fighting on his territory right like the
art of war fight on your own territory
and
and like he could easily dismantle all
the Avengers take them apart piece by
piece
and send them limping back to the
surface and what Captain America
basically says is look we want to avoid
a conflict a service we'll attack if you
kill these guys you don't want any more
bloodshed we don't want any more
bloodshed give us these guys hand them
over we'll take them to the surface you
have my word that they'll get justice
and this is why name war hates the
surface world so much is because while
this is a diplomatic solution in reality
Namor doesn't get anything out of it he
just gets the word of Captain America
that justice will be served but this is
like somebody breaking into your house
and then killing your loved ones and
then in the moment when like you want to
kill them the cops show up and say no no
you can't kill that person justice has
to be served but what justice is there
an eye for an eye they killed your loved
ones you killed him done and it's kind
of a crazy thing of course that sort of
creates an argument where it sort of
spins out into you into like lawlessness
and violence reigning supreme and while
violence is not the answer it is a
answer and it's a very effective answer
and so it's one of these cool little
scenarios here because man was pissed
off about that and so with these guys
you basically sent off to a federal
penitentiary what name war does it's one
of the coolest things ever
what name war does is literally like
send water just back flowing through the
through the toilet in their prison cell
and just floods the prison cell and they
drown now everybody knows that name of
the Submariner is the one who's doing
this and in response to that what name
war does is he basically assembles the
defenders of the deep now the defenders
of the deep here are not super relevant
I mean characters like tiger shark and
Orca go way way back you know different
things like that but a one particular
interest here is basically like a kid
nah now echidna is the chick who looks
like she's like party apart woman she
can looks at the Joker a little bit she
is super Opie and here's one of the
funny things about this is more often
than not when it comes to stuff like
that okay so take for example like a
komodo right kind of side check here for
a second the character of Okimoto was
the original sorcerer supreme back
before marvel legacy number one launched
and we got like Avengers 1 million BC
automotive was confirmed to have been
the original sorcerer supreme and one of
the things about this that sort of
intrigued me is people always reference
like the Marvel encyclopedia like the
mobile handbook Marvel Tarot number one
for 2007 explains all that and that's
one of the things that explains about
echidna is that she's a character who
literally is on par with Zeus she's a
powerhouse and is one of these things
worse like you don't easily go through
and just like face off against her right
I mean she can really really hold her
own in a lot of different ways and
that's exactly what happens like Namor
brings the entire kingdom of Atlantis to
the surface and then in turn like the
Avengers have to respond the problem
with this is that all this is set off by
an address
that Namor makes basically saying look
the Avengers caused this like all the
Avengers had to do was give me the guy
from rocks on oil everything would have
been fine but like this is something
that cannot be tolerated I'm coming
after everybody and so because this
general Thunderbolt Ross basically says
hey look the government's lost faith in
you guys and you can do whatever you
need to do but like at the end of the
day we're calling in a separate team and
so what he does is basically say contact
the agent now the funny thing about this
is that this battle basically leads to
like the risen kingdom of Atlantis
between basically the defenders of the
deep and the Avengers and the fights
pretty cool for what it is I mean you're
talking about some guys who were
relatively even echidna should be able
to crush most of these guys I mean you
know it's like she's able to do her own
thing but it's kind of interesting to
see it's not a great big huge thing this
is what is it this is really kind of
pointing to the fact this is one of
those filler stories is the story that's
kind of thrown in there for the purpose
of like just showing us what the
Avengers are doing at the time but
really like it's all kind of building
the war of realms is what a lot of this
stuff is going into but also like war
the vampires which is pretty cool
the other part of this is that because
of the actions of name of the Submariner
in like launching an attack also
affected the black sea which is part of
the Russian territories what this does
is it invokes the winter guard now the
winter guard aren't super important in
fact they're here for like a hot minute
but for those guys who were unfamiliar
the winter guard was basically Russia's
answer to the Avengers is really what
they worked but aside from that like
there really isn't a whole lot doing
here the battle happens pretty fast and
it really kind of comes down to a
stalemate
it's literally like the Avengers and the
winter guard while they are kind of
fighting each other to a degree they end
up turning against the Atlanteans and
that's when Namor basically calls a
retreat and says it look like we're
going back where marshal our forces and
we'll return yet again and that's
basically yet not a whole lot do and it
happens pretty fast the big takeaway
from all this and this is kind of the
big important thing that goes on here as
you will really two big important things
that go on here is you've basically got
Thunderbolt Ross who's sitting in his
office after the whole things popped off
and he's met by the arrival of the agent
who turns out to be Phil Coulson not
only that what Phil Coulson has done is
basically assembled the squadron supreme
of America essentially like the Justice
League I mean it literally looks just
like him that one chick looks exactly
like Wonder Woman
but like is essentially like Batman more
or less like it's it's the squadron
supreme like it's literally like the
return of the squadron supreme and it's
kind of a cool little thing because what
this does is this sort of spins out and
transitions over to Loki now a little
bit of a follow up here those are guys
who were unaware after the first host
and everything when that when the final
host story arc happened Loki was the one
who basically reassembled the Venge the
Avengers against like the return of the
slide
and at the end of the whole thing the
Celestials basically whisked him away
and we didn't know what was gonna happen
we didn't know the basis behind it or
what the intention or motivation was but
what basically is up happening here is
Loki is met by the arrival of Wolverine
now a little bit of an explanation this
is kind of an explanation of sorts and
we may or may not end up covering it I'm
not 100% sure but basically what
happened in the four comics is Jason
Aaron wrote them is that you had like
old King Thor more or less where really
it's kind like Odin I guess facing off
against especially like Wolverine from
the future were the powers of the
Phoenix force when Marvel Legacy
happened and you had Wolverine with like
the the space stone I think it was but
it was actually like future Wolverine
with the Phoenix force powers it was
cool the art was a little funky it kind
of felt like an unnecessary story but
what this basically does is confirm that
it is kind of necessary that essentially
like in this future all hell breaks
loose that one it looks like Malekith
one of war realms it seems like multiple
people have the power star brand you end
up having Hyperion who basically like
destroys this shield of Captain America
that all things seem to basically pop
off and it's really like it's really the
kind of Wolverines way of saying hey
look like things are getting pretty
right like these are getting very very
very bad here and so you have a very
important role to serve again kind of
feeding into the war realms how this
transitions we don't fully know we won't
know until like the war of realms
actually happens but then from there
what you basically do is pick up with
Janet Van Dyne who's kind of on this
mission for what used to be shield more
or less and she eventually infiltrates
like this crazy dark vampire kind of
place only for her to basically recruit
blade and missive Lee ass blade whether
or not he wants to join the Avengers
which is kind of cool because blades
finally making his return in Marvel
Comics after well really after more than
like a cameo I want to say maybe he
appeared like four times since like
Secret Wars and even then like I'm not
even a hundred percent sure without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]